ces images amateurs sont présentés comme
étant les dégâts dans la base militaire
de yavo rif dans l'ouest de l'ukraine
pendant la nuit l'armée russe aurait
tiré une trentaine de missiles depuis
les mers noire et d'azov la moitié
aurait été détruit en vol par le système
de défense aérienne
les avions ont décollé depuis saratov en
russie ces avions ont frappé sans
survoler le territoire ukrainien
c'est pourquoi nous demandons à l'otan
de fermer le ciel car pour combattre un
ennemi qui lancent des missiles de
croisière sont même entrés en ukraine il
faut avoir un solide système de défense
aérienne
pendant plusieurs années la base de yavo
ryf a servi de terrain d'entraînement
aux forces ukrainienne encadrés par des
instructeurs de l'otan comme on peut le
voir sur ces images tournées par france
24 en 2019 ces instructeurs étrangers
auraient quitté la base me fait vriller
selon les médias ukrainiens et l'otan a
confirmé qu'aucun de ses membres
n'étaient présents lors de cette attaque
mais ces dernières semaines le centre a
aussi accueilli des volontaires venus
des quatre coins de l'europe c'est aussi
sur cette base qui arrive une partie de
l'aide militaire livré à l'ukraine par
les pays occidentaux
yaro vives se trouve près de la
frontière polonaise et à une quarantaine
de kilomètres de le vivre une ville de
l'ouest de l'ukraine jusqu'ici
relativement épargnée par les combats
depuis le début de la guerre de nombreux
civils y ont trouvé refuge au moins le
temps d'une étape avant de fuir encore
plus à l'ouest
des gens nous ont hébergés quelques
jours et maintenant on part pour la
pologne
dans cette région des frappes avaient
déjà visé un aéroport militaire à luz
que samedi l'ouest de l'ukraine semble
de moins en moins à l'abri de
l'offensive russe